what is uh something you've learned from
just being around Joyner for a month
man a lot bro
um I would say he's got the best videos
in the game
you've got one of the best Minds in the
game yeah his team is great right
um they're very focused they pay
attention to detail very close
um they're very concerned about how the
fans receive the show right even the
music
um they're always thinking of ways to be
Innovative and own brand
oh but one thing I remember after I
think it was like the third night
I kept like because I would kill I'd be
killing every show yeah and then I'll
walk out and then it was one night where
they was they was like chanting like Sam
but after I walked off the stage and he
was like yo he's like you got to start
going out there taking pictures
but I'm thinking like I'm thinking like
[ __ ] I Gotta Get Out The Way suit you
know I mean he's like nah go out there
take it yeah you don't want to be the
guy who while the headliners closing
there's like a line of people trying to
take a picture exactly that's something
take away from his shine yeah he was
like nah you gotta take the pictures so
the next day I started taking the
pictures and I start watching my
following go up he came to me the next
day he was like you gotta tell him to
tag you in the pictures yeah you know
what I mean that's how you you get them
die hard yeah like I went up like I
think like 120 000 followers just in the
last month just being on the road album
coming out yeah yeah yeah that shit's
crazy yeah it's been dope bro it's been
a great experience and you've been
killing it on the sink [ __ ] it's crazy
because you got uh the in the game
record that is my son's favorite song
really yes my eight-year-old yeah he's
like loves that [ __ ] song that's dope
we actually just uh got word that the
NBA is going to be doing something with
that this season as well nice
it's not even a song on your uh on your
album no
I feel like those records do well
um because they're like all purpose
records right and me sometimes as an
artist I'd be so concerned about
building out who the Simba fan is I
naturally try to run away from them
records on projects they're like build
the fan base out but I'm slowly starting
to see how they perform on the road so
I'm like I need to mix this in a little
more